as the convoy arrives the trauma of the
last few months is clear on their faces
so too is the sense of absolute relief
it's taken days to make this journey but
they are now safe at this un reception
center
oksana arrived with her two children
after spending weeks underground
she tells me she thought they'd never
get out alive
the evacuation mission started on friday
through the ruins of the as of style
steel works they moved with great
difficulty
hoping the fragile ceasefire would hold
before reaching the waiting buses
evacuees were then taken to this camp in
russian-occupied territory
where they were processed
many of the families of those people
trapped inside the azerb style steel
works thought they would never see the
day when they reached this point
but there are fears for those still
stuck inside as more stories of
atrocities emerge from a city that has
been destroyed beyond recognition
others who were stuck in mario pool
managed to leave on their own taking
advantage of the ceasefire
many of them arriving in battered cars
with stories of terror and survival
inside the aid tent we meet marina
she still can't believe she's here with
her children
on her phone she shows me pictures she
smuggled out on an sd card through many
russian checkpoints
this is the center of mario paul
neighborhood after neighborhoods been
wrecked and newly dug cemeteries she
says are all over the city
there are still many civilians trapped
inside the as of star works and a large
number of fighters who are refusing to
surrender what happens to them nobody
knows
[Music]
but russia has resumed its attack on the
plants making it impossible at the
moment to get more people to safety
for those that have made it out it is a
time to be reunited with loved ones
but the memories of what they have seen
and left behind
will be difficult to forget
alex rossi sky news zaparisia